mein name ist lena schenk und mich hat
diese woche ein thema sehr bewegt und
zwar die zunehmenden proteste die wir
annehmen mit blick auf die ära der
innenminister der csu hat jetzt schon
davor gewarnt das ist proteste von
linksextremen gruppen geben könnte nicht
nur straßenblockaden sondern ist es auch
mit gewalt zu rechnen ich frage mich wie
kann es sein dass die leitindustrie
unseres landes die automobilindustrie
nicht in ruhe ihre produkte vorstellen
kann wie kann es sein dass es keinen
aufschrei gibt wenn jetzt schon bekannt
ist dass mit linksextremen protesten zu
rechnen ist wo bleibt der aufschrei
müssen wir als gesellschaft uns nicht
jetzt dagegen positionieren gegen die
umweltaktivisten und sagen nein wir
brauchen diese messe wir brauchen die
automobilindustrie und verdammt noch mal
wir sind stolz auf unsere
automobilindustrie wir sind stolz auf
unsere erfinder und wir sind stolz auf
unsere ingenieure das ist das thema was
mich sehr bewegt janina und ich muss da
immer zuerst daran denken dass sich
immer dann merke dass in berlin gewählt
wird wenn nachts die helikopter über der
stadt kreisen dann merkt man nämlich
okay jetzt sind wieder werden wieder die
autos angezündet
und jetzt werden wieder jetzt wird
wieder randaliert und das problem ist
aber dass überhaupt kein ziel mehr
erkennbar ist in meiner in meinem kiez
das ist am in mitte am rande von
prenzlauer berg standen neulich auch ein
paar ausgebrannte autos und das war
wirklich kleinwagen sehr alte
autos ohne irgendeinen trotz wert also
es ist einfach gar nicht erkennbar
wogegen sich diese blanke wut richtet
und deswegen ja also bin ich gespannt
wie das noch weitergeht in den nächsten
wochen bis zur wahl aber also die
helikopter sind auf jeden fall nicht
weniger geworden ich möchte hier auch
nochmal kurz vor lesen weil ich das
wirklich sehr bewegend findet joachim
herrmann also bayerns innenminister hat
auch gesagt bestellen bundesweit und
über deutschlands grenzen hinweg dass
sich das linksextremen spektrum
mobilisiert wir müssen mit störungen
blockierten straßen und möglicherweise
auch mit gewalttätigen protesten rechnen
das ist für mich etwas was man nicht
hinnehmen sollte und ich finde alexander
du beobachtest für deine kolumne bei
bild ja immer die presse und was
geschrieben wird wie viel wurde am
bislang darüber geschrieben dass er mit
protesten rechnen müssen ich habe wenig
gelesen was ich sagen darf ich zu deiner
klage über die autoindustrie etwas sagen
ist es nicht längst so dass unsere
videos in enns kernindustrie längst von
der politik aufgegeben worden ist und
ich meine nicht nur die ich meine nicht
nur die autoindustrie sondern vor allem
die zulieferindustrie die dort die
eigentlich den löwenanteil der der
arbeitnehmer ausmachen denn so eine
firma wie mercedes oder porsche kann
sich neu erfinden diesen letztlich
marken wir müssen ihre marke nur auf
irgendeinen
zukunftsprojekt kleben und die können
mit ihrem prestige geld machen weil sie
ihre marke marke dieser marke geld
machen kann haben die ganzen zulieferer
können das nicht und mein eindruck ist
also die dass wir alle eingeschworen
sind auf die komplette abschaffung des
des ottomotors es gibt überhaupt keinen
findet auch gar keine meint der
kabarettist verbrennen das ist findet
überhaupt keine diskussion weil statt ob
man vielleicht die innovationskraft
dadurch anregen kann dass man sagt leute
ihr müsst die emissionen soweit
reduzieren man es ist jetzt nur noch die
freeski es geht jetzt nur noch um e
autos für die auch strom er irgendwo
herkommen muss dieses kann diese ganze
diskussion ist
eigentlich schon beendet und die
autoindustrie selbst wehrt sich nicht
mehr die iaa die du gerade so gerade
erwähnt ist gar keiner automobile
ausstellung mehr ist ein mobilitäts
ausstellung und das logo oder ihr anders
ist da irgendein roboter und in die
drohne und irgendeinen fahrrad
abgebildeten ganz klein ganz
verschiedene noch ein auto wir haben die
deutsche autoindustrie im grunde also so
ist mein eindruck im grunde von
politisch schon beerdigt und ich finde
darüber darüber lohnt sich auch zu
klagen über die linksradikalen zu klagen
das ist mir jetzt wird das das ist mir
zu einfach natürlich hat die politik
auch da längst ist dort längst in der
defensive ich bin nur froh dass sie
münchen ist in münchen hat ist die
polizei in der regel greift sie etwas
radikaler durch oder etwas stringenz
dadurch um sozusagen als in hamburg also
da ist da ist die iaa ganz gut auch es
ist eine spitze gegen olaf scholz der
damals dort ja entschuldige mal also
dass das war ja geduldet das chaos das
war geduldetes rechtsbrecher tun das war
das war das war tagelang wurde diese
wurde diese stadt wegen der während des
gipfels dem dem ob vollkommen anheim
gegeben und es gab überhaupt du konntest
110 wählt überhaupt nichts geschehen
natürlich ist es natürlich ist aber ein
unterschied ob der in hamburg und in
münchen so eine veranstaltung heißt
gewirkt in münchen werden sich die
linksradikalen bisschen schwerer tun als
in hamburg freitags dem gerade ein wenig
die stirn wir uns übrigens richtig
gesehen habe was würden sie dazu sagen
nun ich habe vielleicht an der stelle
die stirn runzeln oder nachdenklich
gewährt weiß ja sehr viele menschen gibt
die der ansicht sind es gibt gar keinen
linksradikalismus also vielleicht
sollten wir auch mal darüber sprechen
dass es durchaus parteien gibt aus dem
linken spektrum die nicht akzeptieren
dass in ihren reihen extremisten auch
schalten und walten dass das vielleicht
auch eine politische ebene ist über die
wir diskutieren vielleicht ist das mit
der grund warum es kein aufschrei gibt
sind woher kommt in erster linie der
aufschrei also wer geht auf die straßen
und ich selber komme aus dem linken
spektrum an das linke spektrum ist ja
das spektrum das gern demonstriert hatte
in den 80er jahren zumindest als ich in
meinen 20ern war haben wir viel
demonstriert und dann passt das
natürlich zusammen oder ist auch ein
teil der antwort auf ihre frage warum
daran aufschreibt da ist weil es nicht
halt diesen aufschrei in etwa etwas kurz
genau die sind sie sind insgesamt
großzügiger in diesem bereich grad in
den letzten jahren kann man das gut
verfolgen deshalb gab es also bei uns in
berlin ist der erste mal dass gerade
angedeutet der erste mai ist ja längst
in berlin wo diese straßenschlachten
fahren ist gehört er links zu folklore
das heißt wie münchen das oktoberfest
dagegen die touristen hin und schauen
sich das an genauso wie die liebe der
drogenhandel in kreuzberg und am
hallischen tor die touristen anzieht die
finden das cool das schaut sich schon
dass irgendwelche serien im fernsehen
bevor blogs oder new york toll toll in
berlin ist hoch droben handel auf einer
straße alexander genze sehr gerne machen
wir ganz kurz nach frau du rein in die
diskussion rein es gibt jetzt ganz viele
themen lässt welches in der tagung weißt
du was
in der tat sind es ganz viele themen und
hier wird auch ganz bild alles irgendwie
durcheinander geschmissen von vier blogs
über linksextremisten und irgendwelche
grünen die gegen verbrenner motoren sind
ich würde übrigens ihnen widersprechen
kroatisch ich glaube es gibt nicht so
viele leute die sagen es gibt kein
linksextremismus es gibt aber gott sei
dank sehr sehr viele leute die sagen
naja bei dem rechtsextremismus die mir
im moment in deutschland haben ist dass
gerade das sehr sehr viel größere
probleme und deswegen wird vielleicht
nicht so viel über linksextremismus
gesprochen weil das eben im moment nicht
die opfer zu tage bringt die
rechtsextremismus zu tage bringt das
stimmt auf jeden fall aber man muss ganz
klar sagen linksextremismus wird immer
gewalttätiger also dass immer mehr auch
gewalt die sich gegen personen richtet
zum beispiel gab es in leipzig die
mitarbeiterin einer immobilienfirma die
wurde zu hause der wurde zu hause
aufgelauert von zwei linksextremen und
die wurde der wohl ins gesicht
geschlagen also die wurde richtig
krankenhausreif geprügelt von zwei
linksextremen in leipzig und dann gibt
es immer wieder auch gewalt links gegen
rechts und die ist auch sehr brutal sehr
gewalttätig und darstellt auch der
verfassungsschutz fest dass das immer
mehr auch physische gewalt gegen
menschen ist und da muss man sich auch
ein bisschen lösen von dieser
verharmlosung ja die werfen ja irgendwie
nur fachleute sondern klar es ist
überhaupt nicht im ausmaß wie der
rechtsextremismus dass es steht völlig
außer frage aber es ist ein phänomen das
immer gefährlich ich habe dass ich habe
oft das gefühl dass in der gesellschaft
das bedürfnis herrscht es muss über
linksextremismus genauso viel geredet
werden wir über rechtsextremismus und
das wird einfach die verhältnisse nicht
gerecht deswegen und ich würde schon
sagen dass bei solchen gewalttaten sehr
wohl es aufschrei gibt und darüber
gesprochen und darüber diskutiert wird
und dass auch vom verein verurteilt wird
sr
22 gern da muss sagt dazu ja
absolut ich bin ganz bei ihnen wenn sie
sagen zahlenmäßig wenn sie sich die
statistiken anschauen gibt es ganz
sicher im ausmaß aus dem rechtsextremen
eck mehr taten die uns auch zugetragen
werden aber ich möchte wirklich vehement
widersprechen dass sie sagen es wird
genug darüber geredet 2017 habe ich eine
europäische bürgerinitiative mit
initiiert mit dem mit dem titel stop
extremismus und zwar ging es darum dass
wir gesagt haben wir brauchen euro
europaweit eine debatte und diskussion
insgesamt über extremismus von links bis
rechts und das beinhaltet sowohl
politisch ideologischen extremismus als
auch lösen und das und themen mit denen
ich mich beschäftigen um eine erfahrung
war wenn wir vor allem links
politikerinnen und politiker oder
menschen aus dem linken spektrum
gewinnen wollten für die initiative hieß
es oft stopp
extremismus wollen wir stoppen wir
kämpfen dagegen aber nur wenn es gegen
rechtsextremismus gibt war geht weil es
diesen linksextremismus in dem maß nicht
gibt der nicht existiert und deshalb
also ich widerspreche ganz wenig weil
ich selbst als hausbesitzerin in den
90er jahren aber auch in den 80er jahren
in den 90er jahren in der fahrstraße ein
extremismus erlebt habe innerhalb
unserer szene der meiner ansicht nach
von seiner gewalt und aggression auf
jeden fall identisch ist mit jeder
anderen form von extremismus und sie
haben natürlich recht also nochmal
zurück wenn sie zahlenmäßig das ganze
sich betrachten und vivaz dass wir auch
eine gefährdung für unsere gesellschaft
bedeutet bin ich ganz bei ihnen das
aktuell ganz sicher unsere gesellschaft
nicht vom kopf auf den fuß oder
umgekehrt gilt gestellt wird aus der
linken ecke in dem maß vielleicht nicht
aber es wird verharmlost
[Musik]